all right and we are live
flashpoint ebon tits what is going on
man how you go over I'm doing pretty
good this morning um feels like a little
tamer week in the world of destiny but
Red Dead will keep you busy if you feel
like diving into that it's there's so
much to do in there I feel like I've
honestly barely scratched the surface
I've played a few hours that because
just trying to go back and forth in
between but just kind of working on
grind in gambits out there this week
we'll talk about that a little bit and
it was just overall enjoying catching up
on the what is it the was it Richard is
that the right Richard hug uh oh yeah so
he's good stuff honestly when you were
going through top five with him and he
had said credit Ric I haven't gave like
Errol in the car because I think that's
that's my jam Corona triggers like like
couple so that was cool oh yeah I am
Louis podcast that was good interview
there and definitely some good insights
especially into legal sides of things so
that tells everything so yeah nice nice
guest on that one much appreciated sir
yes I was actually talking with Lord
Hulk this morning he's revising his uh
top ten of the year surprisingly he had
a Dead Redemption barely making his top
ten so Quahog is funny cuz he likes to
people don't get me wrong he doesn't do
it in four shots right he believes what
he says but um you know I was
questioning you know why he had Red Dead
solo and he just couldn't get over the
controls and he's just like you know I
mean it's not it now if you're playing
even just a little bit that I have it's
not for everybody I mean I can tell you
that cuz it is gonna be a slower game
stories involved things like that I have
a buddy of mine he's out of town or
vacation for a little bit and he's
probably gonna come back you know
probably play it but I have imagined
he's gonna just try and power through it
not really pay attention to the story
and feel like it's not maybe the most
amazing or doesn't compare to GTA cuz it
was a slower game for sure I said learn
played poker for like 25 minutes you
could get distracted oh yeah
yeah I was like so like any time I'm sat
down for a couple of those little mini
games sorry guys read dead tangents
thing but I just
like when you're in the Basecamp you can
play Domino's and I sat down I was like
all right I'm gonna win I want to win
the whole match just to like completely
win one it took a while yes and then
when I got to poker I was like all right
I'm taking all these guys money I'm
gonna like I want to see if they get mad
or anything like that and then I cleaned
them up but it just took it took some
time so I was like I just thought that
was like playing poker and I was even on
the stream I was like this has to be
exhilarating it's like watching poker on
ESPN but yeah it's just there are a lot
of distractions in that game but I can
understand like it's not for everyone
for sure right there's no question like
if you say hey I mean that's kind of the
thing when you say and that was one of
the things that caught your guys podcast
last week when you guys we're talking
about a masterpiece masterpieces are
different for everybody and perfection
is one of those things nobody's gonna
hit now some people are like hey is it a
ten out of ten in certain aspects yeah I
was like if you really enjoy it like you
look at the graphics you look at like
the story the voice-acting stuff like
that really cool gameplay sometimes
feels a little slow things like you know
shooting but do you also like some
people give it you know a a pass because
it's a rockstar game for one right you
go is it Old West and that is the
intention of it so sometimes you have to
put yourself in like the shoes of the
developer so that's one of those pieces
as well when it comes to destiny it's
like we have to put ourselves in their
shoes and there's a couple pieces I want
to get to later in bungees decisions
about things so just kind of one of
those always take everything of a grain
of salt and if you enjoy it play it if
you don't don't listen absolutely and
you would you were quite feisty in the
chat I must say when that subject came
up about a you know a perfect TED score
sort of games double a listen I get what
you guys coming from I think it just
comes down to I think what happens is
developers start to gain just these
great reputations and you know they just
have like certain certain death just
have that standard of excellence that
you're used to so that everything else
is just so amazing that if there's a
little nitpick Joey for the most part
it'll get overlooked as it won't be
harped on as much as maybe they say for
example in your game that comes out and
kind of has you know some flaws off the
top but I'm listen I get you a lesson
some games are not for certain people
you know if you're not into you know
cinematic storytelling deep rich
character building you know red death is
all that man that Greg that is is very
very unique in the way does certain
things and graphic means it's beautiful
but if you're into this like fast pace
boss or walking it's not like that every
time there's your gunfights there's
things you know that kind of thing so it
was interested in man but up your salute
the hope we had them on all your boy bar
fuels and chat absolutely the Lord chat
YouTube and twitch thank you guys for
joining us live this morning hopefully
guys you enjoy the pre-show and trying
to do that to give you a little heads up
that will be out there and getting you
started but this is a dusty podcast
despite how this thing actually did
start which no yeah just pretty much
gonna say um you know for me it's been
it's been real fun for me and destiny I
had I kind of held off into patch 2.05 I
don't know if we gonna get too deep into
it now but um I kind of held off on the
plane until it dropped and man some fun
things happen I got I got the meet bonus
for so describe your meatball experience
because honestly like especially up
until this point when everybody's been
seeing it it's been a thing I've seen
stories about and stuff like that so
give me yours cuz I had mine last week
and it was crazy so like I didn't know
what to expect like I've really not
didn't watch any piece anybody's dream
on what happens when the meatball comes
out I've never really watched it cuz I
was just like you know just so like
what's the word when you're just like
you're so beat down that nothing won't
stop for you oh well yeah that that kind
of thing doesn't happen
so yes playing and I believe the first
round we pretty much washed the other
team we got our primeval out of there
so what run round lead I'm just thinking
everything is normal and then I'm doing
my defensive role you know I got my well
irradiance all that good stuff I'm
picked primarily picking off
Vader's and controlling blockers that
they send on our side and let those
other guys kind of scout out you know
and um yeah that's thing you know you
know we got 275 modes primeval comes and
I'm like wait a minute what the hell is
that and I like I've been in panic it
did I like I ran up to it slapped a
trench barrel escalation protocol
shotgun did I didn't have anymore
that I got died someone res me I threw
the well down when I before I died
though so he kind of helped the team and
then work this yeah we just like ganged
up on it and it was out of it it was it
was out of it pretty quick so I was very
fortunate I had some randoms that
literally helped me save the day you
know with the whole well but um it was
fun it was fun god I got to drop I'm
like oh man this is great like that's
the last thing expected to have it was a
good destiny besides that I have my
finally forsaken excited what man I was
pleased I was pleased I could not
believe it and it was off a public event
and it was the controversial and I was
just so happy I'll just like I don't
even know what this feels like like this
is weird I feel like d1 right that week
this week doing a lot other playing
other modes and stuff like that but you
know pretty much for you how has it been
I don't get it we're gonna get into two
of 2.05 but um how has it been for you
like personally 205 like anything you've
noticed per se you know um not too much
so far have been working on Kenneth some
solo grinds on things for nightfall
stuff like that so I've been working on
stuff that probably hasn't seen some
drastic changes I guess I had the
meatball but sheer luck I know cuz it
was a really low drop right before I had
that moment before so I know that one
was kind of one of the bigger ones but
nothing quite as crazy in the patch I
know there's changes and we'll get to
him but overall just some fun stuff got
a first 100k solo nightfall so no salute
did that one on arms dealer I've got
that one pretty pretty much unwrapped so
kind of what to do in there
again shout out to my crooked Fang with
that have you so if you're ever going
for a hundred K by the way a most and
then if you have people with you go
black out and then honestly have people
with you you can still probably hit 100k
with a buff and so you can even probably
run like cuz I ran solo void singe
heavyweight match game and black out
black hell it's a little harder some
people run momentum if you're going solo
but either way if you get a group
biggest thing is just make sure you got
enough people to shoot and do it quick
mmhmm yeah that one's overall I'm
working on putting together kind of a
solo hallowed lair run there are so what
you are by yourself on that strike and
you get to where for one I hate the
immune faces on that guy so yeah like
the teleport outs of the exodus crash
guy same principle like you give to a
point it's like gone and gone and what
the hell like what is wrong with this
guy why is he always immune but it's
when you send him behind the wall for
the first time and basically the entire
army of score and runs at you if I'm in
the back of the room and I just see a
most fun and run at me it looks like I
was probably a like a one-man army
versus an entire game of Thrones show
like ridiculous with so many ads out
there I'm like stare and I'm like oh my
god so yeah that one's actually kind of
a weird setup for me because I've been
running a oddball setup because if I'm
running just to finish it I'll go pure
solar I'll go solar super and then I'll
go like a sun shot was actually helping
on that one which is I know weird
sounding but the explosions chained when
you have them all run up a staircase and
one explodes and it just goes crying and
you get yeah I got a there's AI got a
play match game if I'm going for a
hundred K so 100 K makes it different
because match game makes it tough so I
actually went solar sins but I went arc
super for the art pulse for the art
pulse grenades and I went
[Music]
the hell did I have my voids up oh I
have the vouchsafe just first scout
rifle for like the to avoid guys
honestly I might even take the void out
on a run because doesn't do me that much
benefit there's much white guys in the
whole thing
questioning about um I had one house
pouch feeling post scout yeah how does
he has a feeling it's it's better than
it was but I still don't think they're
there I guess that's my opinion I guess
are quite good enough like that's
something for you but I tell you don't
speak too soon yo you got I got a gambit
dropped distant relation
I'm not even not even a god rule it's
just like a opening shot and I believe
the other perk is triple tap nothing
special I'm gonna tell you right now my
bygones is in trouble like normally by
bygones go bro I don't it hits like a
truck it's so fast and maybe I don't
know if it's the triple tap with the DPS
dude I mean you know I haven't been
going even the city way I wanted ahjuma
City this whole week I was in there
wrecking things from distance like trust
me when I'm telling my new flow right
now huckleberry masterwork I'll do that
ballon thank you salut salut I got that
build man bro I'm running light
lightning huckleberry masterwork so I'm
gathering yeah generating orbs crazy
then I got like oh I'm running crown a
tempest because I don't have Geo merit
for the for the chaos reach and so what
it is I'm just constantly getting orbs
then I got distant relations from from
anything that huckleberry can't handle
from from distance right and then it's
at that point pick your heavy of choice
I think I got actually got a good
shinobi a rocket launcher roll
drop I got cuz those are happy ones they
track automatically so it's got the
intrinsic tracking wind cluster bombs
and I believe the the sucky perk is
probably like oh no loading holster but
back to what I was saying distant
relation pull that out
box I don't what's the role you got on
it Oh both online are garbage what you
get which guy uh moving target and Zen
moment bro bringing out the box trust me
I got a trash book for PvP I stolen love
scout rifles feel right in PvP though I
could see Peavy even more yes
PvP less so might want the one I was
looking at because I actually saw that I
had two one of them's firmly planted
autoloading holster and range I'm like
[Laughter]
they're not all good so yeah my gambit
drops have been pretty rough so far my
drops have been in other places what
game would drought for some reason but
yeah I like what you roll of Whitman and
I like I like what you doing sounds good
you know so yeah we did have some
changes we can honestly just jump into
the path let's see what we got so
sandbox first quick run-through we won't
go deep dive on all these malfeasance
explosive shadow detonation damage is
increased in the damage against taken
and invaders and I know some people have
reviewed this gun couple of people out
there have like gone over it again is it
still any better still doesn't feel like
it's gonna be meta ending I mean I think
some people have some fun with it in
gambit well taken and the invaders but
generally it seems like it's in the
higher it afire hand cannon so still not
just gonna be quite as quick as it needs
to be for pretty much anything else
right housing gambit but overall nothing
amazing wish endure got a few things
fixed on it got some base damage
increase but it still just it's a
hard-hitting bow but it's a slow bow so
trace rifles those got a lot of perks
kind of unlocked so Auto rifle perks
work for those with all your armor got a
little extra ammo and crucible the
increased sword and fusion rifle damage
in PvE I want to try actual fusion rifle
damage in PV I'm kind of curious if it
was enough because sometimes those are a
nice like just you if you're you know
you can either put like six or seven
little bolts into one big guy you have
like three or four thrall coming at you
you can hit quite a few of them as they
pass through but they never felt quite
enough so I'm kind of curious I still
have a tough time believing swords are
ever gonna have quite the use they did
until they get like exotic feels back to
them
right I feel you don't look at mm-hmm
proximity grenades now have a stat
penalty to blast radius which makes
sense mmm reduce the amount of incoming
and then to shout out to follow-up place
mount by which full choke narrows
projectile spread and he's just like
facepalm and then he's like alright
research time again so I watched it
needs like alright so now you're two
barrels are full choke and ranged barrel
go four and then just a couple perk
activations things like that yeah
general fixes visitability through Titan
banners shield for allies which is you
know kind of a good thing so you can
actually use it a couple little fixes
part Polaris Lance's back to normal
which is good white nail is not getting
that actually it was actually getting a
bonus because it was proc it on two
shots not three mm-hmm
combatants a couple of the enemies were
actually not doing all their you don't
even notice until they're like oh by the
way the game is a little easier heads up
yes have you touched break so now back
to like so that's just general stuff but
rough break through back as the weekly
playlists have you touched it yet I've
touched the initial form of it went
before I got patched in this week I can
touch it this week it just what it is I
got to go to shot though I will give it
a shot since you know the changes you
know I didn't encounter any cheating and
the frustrating thing I guess players
were yeah but um yeah I'm willing to
give it a shot at getting just right now
it just again the first initial taste
didn't really do anything for me I was
very indifferent towards the mode so you
know maybe when I give it a shot again
and I think they need to I don't know
I'm just getting a little I love my
quick play but I'm just getting a little
worn out with Jess clash control all the
time and so I wish a little variety
America yeah I will see like a little
sneak something in there you know and
it's the time for like rift or something
to come back they really just need a
cutoff mode in there to break the
monotony of clashing
yeah whether it's rift capture the flag
you've got shooting and then you've got
points but like have something that have
an objective that moves have an
objective this either it's one point
where it's like a little king of a hill
that like moves are on the map so you
get some like change to it um
rift is still fun because you got a run
in you know buckle over that thing then
run it back and you've got like I know
some people hated or if some people love
drift it was obviously just like iron
banner and many things in crucible it's
better with a team but I need more just
a little more variety and it's like I
don't know if they're waiting for
certain things or they've just focused
more on gambit per se maybe like
crucible kind of got a little split up
hey I'm with you this one I haven't
tested it this week either so you know
caveat the side of my previous
experience
I know people got screwed before being
like oh and my biggest issue with what
with it before and they kind of changed
it but it's still the scoring it's the
same thing I heard from everyone if you
get that middle point and you don't get
them for one in the one in the back you
get nothing
yes that's her that was still like the
big issue is like if the rounds in round
ends in a draw then the match is a tie
so I'm at least you're not gonna get
stuck in there forever
Rock says if the initial fight over the
breaker the team with the most capture
progress will win the breaker if the
time runs out and it's just like okay
that's fine but it's just like if that's
an issue then that's kind of like an
overall issue with the mode it feels
like as opposed to like if both of you
went back and forth on this one make
that just like kind of you're like have
all three points but just make the
breaker move because the big issue is
when that breaker is taken and then you
have to if somebody comes in with a
super and wipes all four of you out
they'll have that point before you can
even respawn you know what's kind of an
annoying part so that was the piece for
me is just like if you were on defense
you could get rekt so fast it was rough
I mean yeah well to get over there but
if they orchestrate and they've got
supers you have no chance if you're
super can't if you can't defend it so
yeah we was still not totally sold no
absolutely he I'm in the same boat I
think it still needs to get that
refinement error with a breakthrough and
hopefully I can find a new place I want
to shout Jimbo in the chat man
definitely I miss mom I know they made
him that was so good and actually it
really kind of saved vanilla destiny to
when they were trying to find their way
with rusev oh I remember that moldy
brought it back I'm like man this is how
powerful we used to feel you know what
those feels back so yes mayhem I forgot
all about that that definitely has come
back yeah I I know I read something
about mayhem somewhere like they're
working on it or something's like bug
with mayhem is that right do you
remember that killing them both tough
I've seen somewhere and it's reddit or
Twitter or something that mayhem is like
we haven't forgotten it it's just like
busted right now and honestly I'd be
like I don't care just throw it in the
mix mm-hmm like just throw that in the
weekly rotation I mean unless it's
busted the point of I mean with vet of
all the new supers now it's gonna be
insane I mean golden guns still heard so
now you're just gonna have played
bruises everywhere chaos reach half
across the map but that's the whole
point literally a motors name it's gonna
be insanity go for it yeah I don't know
how busted it is I mean if it you know
if it really is actually just broken for
some reason I understand but yeah I'm
with you I'm miss Mahan because that's
the quick play and still gets a little
sweaty sometimes if you're in the clash
match that yes sometimes mayhem is just
like veg out like just like melt stuff
go stupid crazy happen is just pure fun
yes peace I miss about mayhem and I mean
you know if you're going for valor and
stuff like that mayhem matches you know
they can be a little quicker crazy and
stuff like that but it's like if you
spend like five resets and mayhem who
cares just veg out have funds to meet
mayhem is like the essence of what could
quickly should be right this
non-stressful mode and you just shooting
it and just with your buds and you know
just having fun
and I think that definitely is a
comeback so like I agree completely
oh try breakthrough this weekend but not
really incentivized to do so it is
honestly like even if that was even in
click
yeah words QuickPlay like I wouldn't
mind actually if it was in both like if
it competitive but also could play just
give us a little variety in the mode be
like hey we're playing break for him
like okay this one's gonna be a little
different right it is after a while it's
like controlled clash control clash
clash it's like I think even iron
banners control and I love iron banners
control I wish that was it all the time
yeah it's still the only looks sets of
PvP I play and there are other game mode
types yes so yeah I was like
breakthrough just throw it in both I
don't think you could you even if it's
like and quickly hopefully you're not
gonna have those people farming so a
gambit had a lot of changes I know
you've been jumping around there
fighting the meatballs I'm gonna cover
these you've been in it a little more
than I have doing a lot of gambit so um
yeah activities with that it pretty much
sleeper simulant now gains the less ammo
from heavy crates down they piled here
baby yeah I'm gonna say the crew that
the gambit police have come from a boy
they got him they got it having two
bricks now is such a difference and even
with my little cheat that I thought I
was gonna do with you know my scavenger
my scavenge linear fusion scavenger arms
not enough because it has to be off the
drop that means you have to get RNG to
get it off a drop for that to kick it
taking so normally I would get the
majority of my bricks from just you know
are standing around and primeval where
you know that spawns and getting a
little ammo bricks fed respawn but um
get to is rough man too is rough you
can't really do much the most I can do
is kind of like um counter in you know
kind of invade people that come in and
you know when it comes down to DPS two
shots do its yeah I think our IP to the
homie they got him they got a ban police
you heathens this is what you wanted so
now this is what you get to deal with
you get to deal with the colony coming
in when you guys are all clumped up
getting that cleans breakers bar Oh Lord
yeah that come but um what else I've
been dealing with a couple other lo
heavies I've been seeing kind of sneak
in Bora Mike I can say I think sleeper
they finally this this is more than
enough to control II that's that o sword
the gimme mo heavy went from 12 up from
six to 12 to 12 I played that I still
couldn't get around playing with swords
trying to melt upon evil I didn't I
didn't think it felt good I was using
the raid sword so that's just my
experience with that fiction issue where
sometimes you know the portal wouldn't
open and you know I never had the
experience before
please the spawn rate of the ascendant
primeval servitor yes absolutely
cannabis ship in sparrow no guarantee
drops quit a protection um seeing
someone dropped from my match but I did
notice on you know I was able to get you
know a player to come in and kind of
take a spot fairly quickly um obviously
I haven't been dropped yet to see the
arm suspension and credit penalties and
all that good stuff take effect but um
yeah and then the last thing or that was
that suck the corrupted but overall
gambit felt good you know playing a lot
of it um yeah it's definitely different
you know what
you know sleepers doing what it normally
does it's definitely different I have to
now change up and I'm actually in a bit
of a rut I don't like what do i do I
don't I can't it's similar to when truth
in all rocket launchers basically got
the one shot per in comes on that's what
it feels like
yes it's like yeah yeah it'll change the
way you play I mean absolutely it was so
overbearing me it was to a point of just
like it was sucking the fun out of the
mode because it okay it took away the
variety if you have the gun then
everybody's on the same playing field
but you do have to be honest like you
know toe snapping someone from cross map
it's supposed to bring fear hi okay but
you should also be able to fight back
you know we can see through walls and
they can be like pre-charge okay here he
comes out bang like there is no if it
was every so often it would like pulse
or if there was something but if you can
pre charge that thing perfect where they
peak and I can't even like take that
shot at you that's the hard part about
that is that like the peeking through
walls lets you pre charge and just
instant dead like there's there was a
really hard thing to counter because
you're so far you gotta look for and
they may move a little bit they still
know exactly where you are and that was
the thing about it so I mean I'm played
against some like I would kind of peek
and peek out like kind of let him waste
a shot and then try and start picking
them off with like because honestly what
I've been invading with lately just
might go figure I don't even care about
anything else I'll just pick them up
with my damn pulse rifle and have fun
doing that Salinas with that yeah like I
love that gun like on PC especially like
people watch my videos and be like man
how's your Ricola that good I'm like I'm
sorry I think it's just PC and that's
what some people have told me like
uncomfortable it's definitely got a
bigger kick but mine is truly a laser
beam or I'll go across map and stuff
like that but it's still just a point
where if I like you know if somebody
sees me and they have sleeper again on
the defense like that I can understand
more where it's almost on defense easier
but man when it was four on offense or
people come in and take a whole team and
then still have the amount to melt the
boss it's just like it's too much ya
know I listen I hear ya I will say this
full disclosure the first time I had
sleepers salt is funny because I went to
invade with one name that guy was
waiting and he must have had he must
have the catalyst or his and I don't
know my so we're sitting there and his
class got me out of here so forth and I
was salty just like Dave I don't like
taste your own medicine there's what
about this next one would be corrupted
strike where I mean I'm just glad they
fixed it so players could go into the
corrupted strike with a six player
fireteam somehow it's just broken not
sure how I don't know if I started it
and people would join her if they would
just literally start the strike as a 16
my never actually check
that mm-hmm but yeah that's just fixed
so now the world of exotics now the one
thing I will say heads up you're not
gonna get the exotics faster right so
they're not changing the drop rate
they're changing what drops when you see
one mm-hmm facts so when a player
receives an exotic they take into
account all exotics the players found
and weight them against exotics a have
yet to acquire lowers the chances of
getting exotics already own exotics the
player does not own yet are and early
generated much higher than duplicates
when receiving duplicates players more
likely to earn armored now that is
actually a smart way to do that if you
do get a duplicate which should still a
random role but it's not as much you
still have a better chance I get a piece
of armor which benefits you because it's
random might have different works they
this is probably the smartest one and
this is one of those where you wonder
like why is it still in the pool all of
these have been taken out of your exotic
in grandpoo right now we got worldwide
zero ASA spades wish under 1,000 voices
malfeasance Lord of wolves and chaperone
whether they're all ones you can get
from bounties requests or specific tasks
not just engrams um sadly though I can't
think of many other exotic weapons those
yeah that's that's most of them and most
of them you get from quests like yes
nice one there were some random drops I
mean there's Queens breaker I haven't
got that I still haven't seen Cerberus I
sometimes for exists say yeah I don't
see it very often then we got like a
whole bunch of love I think you got love
when people who are like doing the
initial release of forsaken but after
that like no and I hear there's a bug
with it right now so that is something
that affects to spread that's not
working correctly so that may you may
even see more of a decrease usage rate
until that gets patched no first exotic
somebody got after patch after the reset
was drunken borealis have to do in the
drumming city ban is ten minutes all
right well den oh you're crushing it
this morning nice yeah yeah that's the
one else new occasionally I'll like see
an invader go like I'm like what the
hell and then two tailed fox kills me
I'm like God
they actually smile what I see cuz is
kind of cool it's cool it's like I like
it I like that it exists out there and
somebody's going for the exotic double
but it was like I'll just see this
little like like this little puff of
smoke at them I'm like what's up BAM I'm
like oh man is that like delayed death
for half a second like I can
nope I'm dead just one of those that
catches being like half the time because
I'm gonna usually see it so that one's
cool and the course first off one hands
MIT course steroid enhancement I guess
listen I got some stuff to say about it
um you know I've again this is all
antidotal just personal experience this
is you know we have to see it in the
wild a little bit longer but I am very
impressed this is my personal experience
um you know obviously I the first thing
I did I went to the spider banners
espana bond excuse me English and I
wanted to see what was giving what so I
picked out a couple you know uh wanted
bounties that I can actually get those
went pretty good now guess what's the
funny thing II I get excited scrap about
these like yeah yeah and I also not only
did I notice describe the scrapper
bounties you know coming up when they
ran and they gave me cores as well
I think they stealth buffed mm-hmm
absolutely I know you're going yup trot
like when you dismantle things now I'm
getting master work cause I would say
yep thirty percent of the time whereas
before I broke down a bunch of stuff I'm
like unless it was a year one thing like
master workers and like mod components
that's a whole different fix that but
like the course as soon as you say that
I broke down a couple things I saw one
pop I was like that's just a normal
weapon what the heck yeah I was like
what's this oh yeah I think they
listened a little bit and they're not
saying everything they buff but yeah
you're gonna be breaking stuff down
you'll get some a few more on the
breakdowns it feels like that's got to
be something they did trapper bounties
and then there's six spider
these yeah you can hold more spend a
little more time on the tangled chore so
yeah that's kind of one of those ways to
use more use of that space nahhh because
as you progress away to the Dreaming
city tangled Shore has less appeal to go
back yes I found myself really getting
the spider by when he's done and not
only that shot the profile of the chat
he says Bungie hooked us up with the
course no doubt you know but I think
that it's like it's not over the top but
it's like a steady one or two core
stream so that I'm not feeling desperate
like that was my problem and no one
behold guess was $5.99 now you that'll
be like I'm literally now like I was
able to all the stuff that I held on
that I didn't have course with I was
getting that now and I'm just like okay
I think this is a happy medium it's not
we're not overflowing in them new part
if you play the game
you'll get yeah I'm getting them like I
said from dismantling stuff and I really
like the scrapper bounties man because
they're giving you cord it can be shards
it's really helping the low economy guys
like me well like burn burn you know
that's what I got yeah I mean those were
it's like do I think the whole thing's
perfect I can probably use a little
tweaks but I mean I'm glad like the
subtle buff was there that I didn't say
because there's no way that's not in
there I was like one of those I want to
like ask the sandbox like people
breaking down is like you buff that like
master work or drop right like you
cannot officially say it but like you
know can you tell me that was cool but
yeah on the other side of that mod
components now it still it there are
like I've seen people get these like
farming methods where it's like work on
this or work on that it's usually just
farm a whole bunch of crap and break it
down farm a whole bunch of crap and
break it down
how does Banshee not have like one or
two bounty I mean I still have you know
six thousand weapon parts and nothing to
do with them and I'm not just gonna farm
random roles on his set of stuff that's
only so much right so like mod
components is the next piece like we
can't ask for all of it once I know but
my components is the other side of this
lake you know the people who run a full
super build like super mods on their
armor for PvP it makes the world a
difference I've seen some persons like
cool guys like that did so yeah that's
the next thing I'm waiting for so we'll
get it in absolutely absolutely
general and this is it right here this
is what bugs me first lion Banshee now
accepts up to 25 guns on seals at a time
I don't care though I don't care at once
it doesn't if it doesn't gonna give me
anything good who gives it I think that
was for the OCD of Edo cuz I remember
like leveling up his music so it's like
it is like click click and shout out to
I think when you'll get into an extra
shout out to them shaders shout out to
the shader delivers master yeah so they
remove the whole time for spiders
material exchange interactions I guess
so shorter I guess if you're just gonna
click on a material BAM
increase the stack size of ghost
fragments 10 to 20 that's good so you
can stockpile a little more and buy a
lot of bounds at the same time reduced
shader dismantled time that's what you
were just talking about it's just so
much for it's just like you barely see
that bar go it's so much focus i work
actually work since that happened i went
through and cleaned up even more shaders
because i was like okay i can i can deal
with this it's a little better but sadly
then when you go to rahul still slow as
hell yes so like the fives are slower
but the singles are quicker I'm like
really doing both um let's see
fix issue where the secret victories
emblem was using the wrong tracker
description completely displays
ascendant chests looted little stuff
like that Queen's bounty purification
ritual and has like clarified some stuff
raid challenge bounties they're supposed
to be in a fixed round kind of round
robin rotation which people are really
annoyed about so that's good even though
somebody said it was the same last week
as this week so hopefully that's
actually on rotation yes and for my sake
nightfall unique rewards will drop more
consistently the longer players those
without a unique drop the higher their
chances of unique reward on their neck
nightfall completion so if you are gonna
grind say hallo lair for that
Mindbenders ambition the more you grind
the better your odds it's still probably
gonna be low but if you grind it like
ten times your ads are your odds are
starting to stack up bloody knuckles in
a chat what's going on bro it's good see
man hey what's up guys we got dinner we
got butt fuel Oscar finally joined us
said for us no you guys are tuning in
thank you thank you
oh the chance resets once a player
receives any nightfall unique your
reward so if you play like arms-dealer
ten times and if that's an easy that be
actually kind of an interesting way to
do it go through the arms-dealer see you
can get a nice stockpile of like non
drops then go play hallowed lair a few
times see if that will help your odds
and be kind of a way if you know there's
a strike that's easier to burn through
yes and then PC just chat yes good yeah
so rundown of patch feeling good quality
life a little bit better yeah I I'm
loving it man I'm actually loving it
because um you know for me specifically
cores were number one exotic drop rates
were right there number two and um like
I said shout out to distant relation
they dropped that I got I'm using that
scalp man it's hard to get out of that
slot especially this is the first time
um I was the escalation protocol shotgun
is threatened but it's the first time as
an energy shot like a energy scout I'm
really using this thing and having a lot
of fun and I think if I get a god role
on that I will definitely master work
and the last one I want to make it about
enhancement course is that because of
the economy being the way it is now the
slow steady stream now as I'm getting
towards the end game it's like okay I
can start thinking about master working
guns now right because now I'm getting
that you know 1 or 2 cores from a
scrapper bounty so if I do a spider
bounty you know I can you know I've got
specific areas to grab these resources
and you know to me it's making me think
about my endgame thing and I know we'll
get into armor later with that with the
12 but um I like that aspect before it
just like trying to survive with this
lack of core got a deal so I'm loving it
so far
2.0 2.0 5 I am feeling it success for me
nice very cool yeah I'm pretty similar I
mean definitely all steps in the right
direction these continue patches are
good we got two patches in a month yes I
mean we got the mid month we got October
and I mean festival lost is about to
wrap up so we're gonna kind of roll into
the this weekend bungee festival us is
your last week now we'll jump into a
little bit later like our new thing to
do but we are wrapping up has until just
Tuesday November 6 if you guys won't
Grande out any other piece any other
masks poor story if you're still waiting
for that this is your time work your way
on those pieces but we got a new quest
yes what do you think about that oh boy
[Laughter]
let's go let's go you obviously um based
on data mining and stuff we all know for
the most part that this quest is going
to be most likely tied to the exotic
thunderlord quest and this thing right
now is really getting the community very
riled up as well as far as the the way
it's being presented so you go to
obviously demand that you get the
request you know and pretty much quote
me if I'm wrong it's just like get
legendary engrams right and that kind of
comes towards your progress and at the
end of the day I mean it literally can
be done you can even be cheap and just
not cheap but you'll it'll just go to
Raul and buy the 10 or whatever it is
and get it completed that way the issue
comes down to time gated content and I
see a lot of commentary on it so I'm
gonna pose the question back to you well
look I know how I feel about this but I
want to let you go and I'm gonna say
like with with this question in
particularly do one did you get did get
it done did you do it and to how do you
feel about time
gated content in general so first off I
got it done just naturally playing so
don't go by the engrams it
so easy to finish like just playthrough
I was doing night falls I think I got
half of it done like the what was the
Dameron arms dealer yeah I was working
on that next thing you know I was like
BAM done they were dropping all over the
place so like it goes so quick do not
spin your shards not not worth it at all
time gated content for me is it's weird
like if you're gonna time gate this and
it starts with Amanda holiday and
festival lost and it's a three week
event and it's a three week quest why
did it not start on the first week
that's stage one yes so I feel like if
it's gonna be tied to the events that
coincide with the weeks of the event
like the three weeks in the Dreaming
city that rotation is its own thing but
if you're gonna have a three week
festival lost on three requests why do
those not coincide you know my suspicion
is because we are going to get heavy
machine guns with black armory
absolutely so those are going to somehow
tie in through each other so we know
that's gonna be a thing and that may be
the incentive behind it but honestly the
time to get it stuff kind of sucks
personally I'd say um this I've noticed
community is definitely going crazy I
guess I have to start wearing my you
gotta call me like a like my corporate
hat are you a Bungie shell Bungie so you
know Lord shill or something because
alright here's my deal now in theory in
general I don't have a problem with time
needed content that's just a [ __ ] needle
thing like I really don't it doesn't
bother me when they're like hey week one
is that we had this discussion with Dee
what does it shatter throne or whatever
was yep and I was like okay cool I'll
get it when I get it we don't say it's
so the game is in a state where it's so
much to do that it doesn't bother a
person like me I do understand for the
rest of the community that it does
bother how you know that they will get
annoyed by that however this one I was
like I have them in because when they'd
like you said I was in the middle of a
strike
it just got done so my whole thing is I
don't have a problem with time gauging I
have a problem with just that one step
where as you look at something like um
the Polaris Lance which was time Gator
I thought that was handled better cuz I
believe it was like maybe two to four
steps before you under yep a lot more to
do
exactly so to me this was such a minut
step that it was like you coulda gave us
another step to have us wait a whole
week for something so simple so that
part of the that's the part I really
empathize with community that's the part
I'm like that's stupid
maybe they got to tweak that and then
you hit the nail on the head you know we
all know again Lord shale what what's
going on but it's trying to they're
trying to obviously mark it thunderlord
right at the release of black army I get
it I get the timing but like you said
there's that one week before where this
could have come out and then kind of
synced it a little bit better now that's
all I really have to say on it as far as
that but um yeah there's a little bit
more steps man like this one little step
and that's it then it's like wait next
week and I'm like okay justjust handle
it better no problem with time getting
but just handle this particular I don't
think it was really thought out really
well yeah I mean I'd agree with that
like not all time gated stuff sucks cuz
I mean as we are in a good and it also
depends on where destiny is because
previously you're one of dusty to when
you're working on that quest if you did
just like alright sweet I got the first
part of the Polaris lines quest you burn
through it cool cool well crap now I
gotta wait another week so it wasn't as
much to do now there's a lot to do
gambits going triple to play today
don't forget about that guys triple
infamy going live the rest of the week
yes sir when you have all that stuff's
going on it feels a little better when
stuff's like okay I can kind of
understand and it would be like yeah as
long as it's kind of timed fairly
decently with the drops of you know
black armory kind of color sides and
maybe if this quest actually leads into
it there's a little more you know a
little more going on a little more lore
but this is literally like pick up a
just hang up they're so short and
missing post got everybody was like a
new quest done yeah it was it was like
there was nothin to it
I agree that Dad was was to be banished
was I think I think you're owning that's
exactly the problem I had were so we'll
see you know next week
what the next step is okay go over here
and shoot ten guys all right now wait
another one so it's just kind of the
balance of how much content we get and
honestly we've got more content than we
would ever have expected before sake in
the live updates have been good the live
team's been doing really well like first
of all lost was solid better than
basically I'd say probably any live
event before because just the amount of
like the masks had a purpose you leveled
up the armor that you actually got when
Forest had stuff to go for we actually
had an exclusive weapon that like helped
everybody level up all of those pieces
were a nice combination of things in
just handling this find a little cherry
on top with a little bit more depth what
is it like that icing on the cake right
and again with nitpicking because for
the most part we have to write festival
the loss has been a success like it this
is the vent notoriously has had bad
destiny history it was the official Lord
shill moats and other prices of
everything it was yeah you know again
make things that they can improve on I
think they will learn from it and then
we'll see what happens yeah that
definitely a good one to talk about yeah
good step in the right direction if they
can just keep this level of live content
going for something like the dawning
then I'll be impressed so we'll see how
like this January and the dawning goes
cuz that'll be the next one mm-hmm but
I'm gonna be excited about heavy machine
guns cannot wait for those oh yes Bungie
felt like explaining what on earth is
going on with your armor or section
[Laughter]
general breakdown as you guys know you
have now when armor drops either arc
void or solar kind of damage resistance
and you have five tiers of that so
basically the way it works every little
like little block on your resistance is
worth one person
damaged resistance that's overall for
that damaged type so if I have five
pieces of armor
all of them have Ark and all of them are
full that's a total of 25% damage
resistance to any arc damage yes so if
you stack a damaged type and you know
like hey if I'm gonna go against say I
want to solo the nightfall and it's arms
dealer what's a lot in their cabal so
it's gonna be a boatload of solar okay
so if I see if I have a set of armor
that's full stacked full master worked
and that's where hopefully the core
economy will help this kind of 25%
damage resistance against solar so
that's gonna make that even more
survivable I'm gonna let you crank up
the night glow modifiers a little bit
more and help you manage all that stuff
that you're facing this is that like
kind of starting to min/max your armor a
little bit more yes so this is again
they're delving a little more into these
are Beach RPG pieces here and I have
different sets that mean more now you
have perks and different damage
resistances there's a little tiny little
part of me that wishes I could reroll
the damage resistance though yes yes
because sometimes we'll be like hey crap
they're all they're all you know
whatever if I could pay twenty shards or
something to reroll this one to an arc
resistance or something just to help
match that set a little better that
would be kind of cool the other piece of
the little blocks as you fill in art
solar or void whatever you're wearing
yeah each one of those is also a
percentage against any attack while
you're in your super so that is the
other piece that is going to help you
because Master working before was like
alright what are we going yeah so things
around pretty much yeah it's like you
had the arcanist solar and stuff and
they really never clarified that you're
harder to kill in super when you have
these things Master work they never said
that's this dude who came out it was a
thing before in d1 mm-hmm so now they're
finally kind of clarified to say it's a
thing in d2 so this is nice to see and
get a little clarification I'm not sure
why it took them this long like a year
but that's like where the random roles
and stuff come in and honestly it's just
nice to see that it's a thing because
personally yeah gives me more incentive
to actually you know go for a very
specified set for certain activity
right I mean if I'm gonna go fight what
would be a good example say if I'm
working on the hollowed layer I want to
like not be worked over by Ark which
would probably be the biggest thing
between the bouncing those grant
bouncing grenades by the way from those
Chieftains who doodles Mansell that is
why you'll never you'd never ever ever
ever ever run arc singe on the hallowed
lair you will die because the boss and
those bouncing grenades both will kill
you but that'd be one where if I go
solar singe but I go a full set of arc
on that one it's gonna keep me alive
that much longer so 5% if you have it
full stack would make a difference so
this just starts leaning a little bit
more of what we were talking about last
week with destiny 3 going that much more
into a hardcore RPG yeah I'm very I said
this section it's for you because you
are the armor connoisseur you're the guy
that before Forsaken was going down you
were like cog I don't hear nothing about
armor
this is this is frustrating me like they
better do something it's half of your
inventory and it actually takes up more
of my vault because there's so many damn
rows here Mike I can find my good role
on a weapon like I know if like I've got
two or three I'm like kind of keeping
both see if anything's good but I don't
need ten because I know about eight of
them probably or trash but when it comes
to the armor you can have like 50 rolls
and you never gonna be like oh I'm going
into linear fusion for this one I want
to try it out okay and pull my linear
fusion stuff out of my vault I want to
go Rockets pull that sniper pull that
like that's just those heavies alone so
I mean there's so many rolls
I have way too much armor let's just say
that my fault is a problem still go read
fallouts tweet as well they're like why
is your vault full and he's like these
situations when they done do little
patches and they're like oh by the way
this is good now what I get handsome
what if there's a patch that comes out
and says oh by the way you know rocket
lunch will reload or just got like a 50%
buff you're like hello like I I hear you
on that I I guess I do it selfishly only
for specific arm things that match my
playstyle yeah sound like you're
hoarding like you you sell a also I'm
like the GRANDMONT and prevent build
thousand cats like broke I'm not arguing
honestly I've fully am agreeing to that
and honestly some of its just like
because I'm still not like I mean I'm
close at this point I'm basically I can
be 597 and 600 so I mean I can max the
character if I want to so I'm finally at
that point where I'll actually spend
some time clear and crap out but for a
while it was just I want to play I don't
want to stare at my ball so for a while
let's just throw everything in there and
just keep moving on and then it's got to
the point where I was like crap now I
need to spend like an hour and just
clean stuff out which switch so you guys
can thank yourselves for that one but
generally it's just one of those the I
save as much as I can because I never
what I might build I'm gonna want to do
and that's why the same thing with the
arc solar and void I was like I don't
know what my specific specifications are
so then so even even if like my hoarding
was aside it would be a point where if
you have arc solar what if you just play
like okay sometimes I go snipers
sometimes I go super herb sleeper and
then sometimes their shotguns involved
if you have those three pieces and you
have like an arc solo and void set for
those three and that's a lot of crap
alone like it's gonna add up so I just
got a pair my bolt down but overall it's
nice to see but this is a thing yeah
absolutely and I thought about you with
this yeah so I mean this was cool to dig
into notice the understanding a little
more and then they did say as well if
you go like 15% void and then 5% arc and
5% solar but you have all of your light
sections on that piece of armor all of
them are still masterwork fully you
still have that 25% resistance for your
super so sandwich resistance is one each
little block is towards your super no
matter what type it is so it's not like
you know your highest one is your max
super it's all together which is cool so
I think that overall is and this is the
type of stuff I was waiting for why they
had to wait until like a week before the
damn forsaken came out to tell me about
it I don't know but it could have been
that long and development Native know
but I'm just very glad that in general
Armour has a purpose I wish it was a
[Laughter]
price of port like the price of course
versus
your benefits sometimes for me it's like
1% versus a corn before this economy
change was like that's not worth it now
okay I'll probably spend a few more I'm
glad they got my boy happy they they're
slowly transitioning into that mid max
game and that armour tuning game that
he's wants and according to the room was
like we said last class point you know
d3 is supposed to apparently piss the
casuals off with the level of debt they
intend on going Zack I think they're
setting things up what do you think yeah
it's all in how you phrase things and
that's one of those things some people
have tact some don't DJ's like the best
at handling everything without saying
anything but it's how they present it
something like the division is almost
and that's why I was like there are
points where like I mean dad has even
said it before can I have a number on my
experience bar if you go full RPG or
more even not you don't have to go world
of warcraft but not gonna argue just
make more things transparent if you do
mmm-hmm don't make it quite as vague and
say hey this buffs this hey this does
this tell me hey this you know if a
supermodel like you know you have your
supercharged time or something you can
look at your stats be like hey this
lowers your supercharged time by 10
seconds to text we and have some
something somewhere on your character
screen that says supercharge time and it
starts at 5 minutes exactly or whatever
you throw a supermodel there to be like
oh it went down as opposed to people who
have to literally record their screen
not move and be in like a cave somewhere
where people are videos but it's the
point of late if you want more of the
casuals to not be overwhelmed to be like
I have to go watch a video to understand
everything put it in the game right but
the other problem outs to that because
division went so deep on like throwing
7,000 numbers at you you're like what
the hell does all this dos just do right
so yeah so it's a balance between those
two but them if they handle it well and
make some things just a bit more
transparent if I like mouse-over super
mod say hey it reduces your you know
super cool down and what would it bet
you say if it's five minutes and it's 20
seconds then it's like you know by five
percent
2% or whatever it is like put a number
on that so people can look at that and
just know what it does not just be like
lowers your super time you're like by
how much how much right like why do we
always have to like do research and do a
video unless your point no good point
good point and I think I think you
actually wanted something because with
with 2.05 I even noticed they even try
to improve descriptions within the UI of
certain weapons and certain exotics so
again baby steps in the right direction
are we to where we need to be all the
way no there's still a lot of things
that we need tangible numbers or
tangible definitions like what does that
mean
how much do I increase what increases
how long you know I mean and even things
like um you know status buff timers and
stuff like that you know those type of
things really help with that whole
process so I'm with you man I'm
definitely with you and that's when it
kind of will become that games game MMO
that it needs to you know eventually
meet generally just nice to see and and
again this is the transparency and stuff
that we've been seeing more and more of
and overall thumbs up so just keep it
coming guys thanks ah so if you guys
haven't seen rolling around Twitter if
you just don't use Twitter honestly
these were pretty good so the one that
seemed to be the winners are pretty cool
so you've got basically within ribbon
you've got all the people with their
chicken masks and the chicken emote
which is fitting and it was just the
fact that it's like within ribbon itself
so they need the rain which is say I
love the traveler traveler travel or
meta playing the guitar yes gall & gall
yeah perfectly timed so literally the
best fire team ever Jack that was
honestly if I had to go like favorites
like some of these are cool but
literally your your team is like Jax
feel like the other team is like I'm
outta here I'm done this is amazing yeah
and it was just the fact that that team
had a coordinator
shaders on yes it was like and I think
they all look like they have Red Rocks
broadsword - so it's like that took some
good nations hello you have the meatball
versus the meatball face Oh actually no
that's the older one when you do [ __ ]
like have you watched the movie it by
the way yes you did okay the new one
yeah oh he's about the new Oh laughter
on the old school no no the new one
obviously new one that's worth this even
the next one came from that that's the
word that dances from gotcha the body's
dancing back and forth yes that's trippy
as hell
hilarious so that one's good this just
looks like creepiness in the mask and
then y'all doing this thing yes
but yeah overall these were pretty cool
just like you know what the ones they
picked I think or quality so overall I
think some people have some fun with
those and then the friend quest is out
there so if you got friends who haven't
tried does me this is a good time now I
kind of want to reach out and see if I
can find somebody to get myself through
this one because you know would be nice
to actually knock out because you got
the cool shader stuff like that but
overall or for a friend is just kind of
a nice way to bring people in cuz it's a
good time like if you want to tell
somebody is destiny good now is one of
the best times to say that probably is
yes DJ saying it means for you to come
back he's like I'm waiting three listen
man is I'm telling you it's as good as
it's ever been and yeah I definitely
recommend now you know especially if you
know might catch that sale they got the
refer-a-friend going on they're giving
you all the content giving your wall
mind and curse packed in they're not
forcing it so it's just like it's a good
time man it's good yeah so generally
it's a good time to play if you got
friends that ask that question now it's
worth it to me like I mean if you want a
good value of a game that complete
collection of d100 cyrus warm lined and
forsaken it's worth so much count like
it's just worth a lot of time like you
can spend a lot of time if this is your
type of game if you like shooters and
the way they feel Bungie still does it
one of the best
other than that we've got the lost
cryptarch quest going on so we're
getting started with that piece or for a
friend is going on they've got some
known issues you guys can read about
those they're staying 150 rpm Scout
rifles may not fire at their intended or
a quote that I was like oh I didn't know
that yeah so depending on what's got
rifle you're using mine somebody in chat
said something I don't understand sorry
standard movies of the week and then
they kind of talk about down here
they'll be posted and whether it's you
know improve quality of life or
conversations over crucible just let
them know just if you like say something
to Bungie or Cosmo or Dylan or deeds do
it constructively they're not gonna
listen to expletives and curse words and
crazy ranting oh come on do this this
sucks blah blah that is not how you help
any of that stuff work just like do like
have a methodical thought like sit down
slow down and be like hey if you were
the developer of this game how would you
like to hear about your feedback the
same way that's not too hard do upon to
others as you would like to be treated
that's a pretty standard rule for life
so treat them the same way they put
their heart and soul into these things
so it's worth being decent about all of
that so yes please be respectful yep
other than that we have so it's just the
refer-a-friend stuff so you guys can
actually see like the link so you'll
actually get the borealis from doing it
even though already have the gun
I guess there's just a way to guarantee
to get it which is cool
you'll get the murmuration ship and then
complete a nightfall with a friend
you're gonna get the ornament which is
like that animated ornament which is a
kiss I like an animation on a gun that's
actually unique I won't know if it's I'm
gonna get like lose my mind when I'm
looking down sights but you know anima
cool and exclusive emblems are always a
thing yes and then if you were for
multiple people you will get bonus one
get a double rainbow crazy Sparrow bonus
new Sparrow ornaments which is a weird
thing that's kind of why I want
to bring this up yeah very interesting
you're out with an ornament like it's
not a shader it's it I don't know if
it's just a specific or exclusive
sparrow or gnam maybe it just is a
specific shader for it but it's just a
weird way they phrased it yeah I agree
kind of weird and then just a bright in
Graham I guess for getting them in there
and then just the quest steps you can
actually look through and see what
you've got to do quite a bit of stuff
actually so a few things and it's your
way to kind of get somebody into it as
well generally it's just a nice piece
for people coming in that's right do you
say singing I need my refer a friend
quest done man I need this stuff off you
yell back it'll pick up the game so I
can get my free loop so we got one more
piece I feel like I had it out here yeah
and let's talk about it
let's talk about it yeah now if you guys
are part of the Destiny community you
may have heard about this and honestly
it's one of the really cool things that
the Destiny community has come together
to do is Guardian Kon and honestly the
biggest pieces of fundraising they do
for st. Jude's amount of money they have
raised over the past few years has like
grown kind of in a 2x fashion which
blows me away every time Guardian caught
the big beat up it's some of the major
streamers get a lien bro man couple of
those guys started it it's grown into a
huge deal I mean Ninja made it out to
the last one if you guys watch twitch at
all I know you know who ninja tales and
this year though they still go on like a
fancy
yeah Drake knows to so this will be a
cool thing Cognito and I are actually
looking at getting out to Guardian cone
so we will hopefully be there not sure
like we're not probably gonna host a
booth or anything but maybe work on
trying to do you know have a have a meal
in a place you know kind of do meet up
something like that maybe if people are
interested but this will be cool like
because this is what cognitive and I met
friends ago it'll be three years we got
dancing webcams guys cuz it's honestly
just people were passion about destiny
if you guys are watching this podcast
you probably are too and it's just a
whole bunch of people coming together
they'll do panels with people talking
about other podcasting or YouTube or
just events they had Gambit out there
last time we don't know if there's gonna
be some exclusive experience out there
this time because alright let's let's do
it let's do our homework we've got black
armory coming up spring will be what is
it joke as well think so and then summer
so we should be telling I'm running a
penumbra we should be like number should
be out I think in July I think yeah
because if you go December spring
mmm-hmm you want to say what April we
would say April joke as well see I can
wait that long maybe this is it depends
on the summer but yeah maybe this is the
number of time I can feel like I mean
technically spring starts in March I
always forget that it starts that late
so pretty much gonna be in December
they've said that yes now if they're
gonna space it right you would think you
almost got a jump like hit in March
almost as soon as you can to space cuz
you have to have a space you are in some
breathe to be a number but I mean July
August September you I feel like it
almost needs to be like III like three
being like you know September's big
release like that's why it's like if you
wait for like some release after e3 it
feels like weird timing I don't know but
something's gonna be related to Guardian
con if they do it again whether it's
whatever's coming in September maybe
sort of a mode they're testing out maybe
stuff with penumbra but you know Bungie
usually will send at least the community
manners out there it's cool to meet a
lot of these people and it's just a cool
place to meet a lot of people that
you've either probably watched in
YouTube videos right we've seen them on
Twitch and then you can actually just
walk up and shake their hand so it's
like destiny like most of us do it's a
cool place to hang out and they went
plush on this one whoo oh it's boozy oh
yeah I like this oh Rosen Shingle Creek
it's a resort out there in Orlando
Florida it's really close to Disney
actually pretty damn close got a golf
course got indoor heated pool they got
for like heated pools the conference
center in there there's restaurants so
what they tried to do this time is
basically make everything
on location so if you just go on from
the airport like take an uber over there
you technically don't have to like rent
a car or leave it sounds like if you
just stay at the resort for a day or two
you'll probably be good yeah you don't
have to go wander around and stuff which
is kind of nice so that's actually
really cool you can get just a basic
weekend pass for 80 bucks if you want to
get the like premier pass and premier
plus you can get some like you know
exclusive bling stuff like that but
overall like if you just want to go to
the event 80 bucks for a two-day event
it's gonna be a lot of cool stuff so par
5 say in golf I'm like of course you're
saying golf as like mitts in your name
that is that is your name so golf was
definitely thing but the biggest thing
and we haven't actually worked it out
yet but they do always do their
fundraising streams and things like that
and it's just a really cool thing so if
you don't follow Guardian con now follow
them on Twitter just check them out see
as they're going along they do that
crazy like charity streams and all that
type of stuff so I mean I know you sent
me this as soon as it went live come on
I know it's like I'm rambling just about
all of it but like what do you think
about this oh man because like first of
all I could say we already don't Haitian
between me you like I said we went
though when it was destiny laughs here
it was that yep so it's like it's good
to see them return first we got a shout
out you know these guys are Italian bro
man cave like you know these guys just
the amount of time and effort that they
put in to set this thing up to make sure
things go smoothly to get people who
love this game you know to really come
together it's really cool and like I
said it's just it's it's a brotherhood
into karate it's fun
people do cosplays you know there's
games is full and then you know that was
the original experience and that was the
fairgrounds never disclosure
but was very appreciative whole
disclosure but when I seen announcement
for 2019 and I'm like this is what I'm
talking about this is that
Premium lowered Cognito experience even
so but so you know I do
oh yeah pushes all be bro since like you
know what I do they hit it with Lord
kick is like hey I want to go but it's
probably like he would never go to a
destiny type car right Lord King oh damn
is my birthday I was gonna go with you
get the guard I got fancy enough to get
Kings attention this is really nice I
like the fact that it's all on on the
grounds you know apparently from
listening to the stream you know they
they're gonna have more than enough the
convention space actually is on site and
they can even add to it which sounds
really cool you know from a commute
standpoint Tampa was a little tough you
know getting around sometimes was a
little you know not tough but well I'm
more expensive than it would be to do
this this would be closer to the airport
just logistically it seems really good
and you know apparently when these
things go live and all this you know all
the stuff goes live you know there's
gonna be some deals you know cut in
conjunction with the hotel and all that
stuff so if you guys have never been to
one
I really really suggest you guys try to
make one and this looks like the year
because according to Gotham these guys
they're trying to continue this
partnership with these guys
yeah the Rosen Shingle Creek rosalie
right so apparently you know this this
is supposedly like the start of a new
you know arrangement long term
arrangement so if it goes well this year
we kind of expect it and I hope it is
you still got you know it's gonna be
fourth of July weekend a date for you
know you've got still got you know
Disneyworld whatever right there you
know it seems like a perfect storm and
again if we follow suit last year I
believe Bungie reps did go right yeah
Cosmo Dean's brother erdal snow and
Dylan or that right and the year before
I believe when I went there was one year
I went you didn't go I was the following
year maybe the 2017 I want to say yeah I
was it was the year after we went
because I know neither went in in this
year like 17 would
when you went right so 17 I was so low
and that I got a chance to meet um deej
Cosmo the whole crew on what his homies
name actually something he was from um
he was part of the third studio I
believe all my character yes so I got to
meet the Vaqueros vision because this
was the first time they were gonna debut
it you know on PC so that was cool you
know you get to meet your favorite
content creators DCP all those guys you
know khakis I mean it's just so cool by
if I got the only person out that I
haven't met and I really want to meet
its like unknown player I think I missed
him a couple other people I kind of
missed you know but it's a fun event man
and like I said if you're a hardcore
Disney fan if you got the time in the
area pop on through flashpoint will be
in the building we're working on some
bands working on I guess we're gonna be
there just cuz we love the game and this
is like the mecca of destiny so poor
choice of words but after it's like and
it looks just like if you're gonna have
vacation you know it's life or anyway
make it a little extra a day or two
around there I mean you call so it's the
fifth and sixth so it itself is gonna
take place on Friday and Saturday
yes so that's the two events the fourth
is on Thursday so I mean if you like fly
out Wednesday leave them know fly out on
July 4th which may be crazy for travel
but I mean that actually might be an
okay day to travel because people are
gonna want to be where they are for
traffic the prices are lower ain't it if
you on that day if you flying out the
4th flights it's it's cheaper yeah and
you just come back on Sunday so don't
make it too crazy you could even just do
one day like if you're in the area want
to go in and just check it out so if
you're in the area somewhere in Florida
and you want to drive in for a day 50
bucks check it out have fun you know
cool people do it two days they're gonna
have some night events they did you know
some cool stuff last night yeah the nice
stuff for you late so yeah tell ya tell
ya it'd be some nice shindigs and
apparently the the facility has like
three or four restaurants on site so
yeah half
go out and go too far all the stuff
we're talking about the pools and it oh
man
this is the one go-to guy yeah I didn't
deal with the hard floor of this it is
carpet everywhere oh you're not gonna
have that sore feet from walking on
concrete for like so many hours it's
true though like you don't think about
that until you do it just love concrete
as opposed to anything with squish is
gonna guess much better so yeah I mean
they got in room/dining they got for
your restaurants so minutes it's just
gonna be a really cool place but overall
that is something we're definitely
looking forward to so that got announced
tickets will go on sale and also the
hotel block that is related to this
event also goes on sale and it is
midnight Eastern November 23rd so
definitely be ready for that one
it's basically Black Friday's one all
that goes on sales so your midnight
shopping maybe start with a hotel room
the ticket the hotel rooms maybe harder
to get them taken away actually got a
correction um according to Gotham them
the tickets go up first they advise you
if you guys are gonna go go to the
follow a guardian Connor on Twitter
whatever they'll put the link up when it
goes live they said get the tickets
first do not book on your own with the
hotel because what they're saying is
well you get the block right there then
they'll give you the link for the block
that you'll get the discounted deal and
I believe it don't quote me maybe
130-140 a night I think it's that one
forty one forty yes so um that so
basically that opens up once you buy
your ticket
so it's ticket and then hotel room so
don't block don't get on your own cuz
you really miss out on that kind of a
deal if you want to stay on site right
in the heart of things in them in all
the glory the premium experience
pouchiness that is Guardian kind and
Rosen Shingle Creek you know trust me
man like I say it's worth it this is a
good one to go to for your first one
yeah it looks like they're gonna do it
right I mean last year got crazy big
they had some big names out there they
did some cool stuff with gambit there's
still a lot of panels they're just
people I mean we were there just like
going out meeting some people having fun
checking out a panel talking to people
that I know and just like just taking it
all in and it was just one day I'm like
the fact that it was like two days and
so long and you don't have to rush and
you can actually enjoy all of it that'll
be that'll be nice
got a quick question um yeah any content
creators ebon tiss wants to meet that he
has it oh no I was gonna say there's a
list I'm sure I did meet dado when I was
at the first one with you yes I think I
bumped into fallout at the time but
hadn't actually followed him as much
pretty sure I said hello cuz like I'd
seen the name I saw him but it wasn't
like oh I didn't have it all together
yeah so definitely would definitely like
to say hi cuz I've been following his
scientists late ones like Esther cross
you got hounded she got there when we
cross together so a lot of those bigger
guys for sure just say hey just you know
always enjoyed their content as well
some other guys that you see out there
so like cool guys when you pointed me to
lately who's a pretty cool guy and I've
seen engine pops gonna pop there and
just it would be cool just to meet those
people put a face to a name and chat
with them for a second cuz I know our
piece of podcasts and videos and things
like that and they do that as well and
it's like you know just beyond that's a
person they're humans they're people
everybody's like oh these are awesome
streamer and stuff you meet him in
person different and that's why I was
like it's nice to just walk up and say
hey shout out to on fire team chat I met
them both both yeah they're really cool
man shut up to a boyfriend Marabella
who's that I no longer would I didn't
but he was part of the thing um I don't
believe Sean finnegans ever gone to a
guardian guy he's been at e3 definitely
getting there yeah definitely Gary's a
mainstay he's always there and CJ Gibson
went one year so CJ Gibson's really cool
so I would like to meet CJ as well
because I met Dustin and Fran actually
at the wing place at guarding the first
one I met him that night before and then
I met Cosmo there
Dylan I don't think was actually a
community manager at the time so right
in
I misdeed completely I gotta pick Eve's
too late that's cool and then trying to
think so yeah but yeah so I got to meet
friend he wouldn't be there but yeah I'd
like to meet CJ and Sean I think seems
like a cool guy and kind of appreciate
Sean's level at some point having some
world experience having that ask let's
say an elitist is the wrong word but
he's definitely got he's more of a
hardcore and he's just like it was like
he always seems like a cool dude
definitely photography and stuff like
that but CJ just always seems like kind
of the the family family he's the dad of
the group and that's in the nicest way
that seems like an awesome like has fun
and chill doesn't get too hyped up play
could do everybody has yeah just a good
dude overall so like I'm looking forward
to meet a few of those guys hopefully
they'd be there so what about you you
got any content you got any people that
you want to add off to your list shaking
I want to see my usual faces I want to
see my DCP obviously you know I want to
see actually I want to I want to talk
about men in my future I want to haven't
talked to him since he got the position
at Bungie temporarily which is my watch
Holtzman I'm a huge Holtzman fan so I'm
definitely hopefully I want to see if
the old school I'm actually say also the
new school planet destiny guys go
because Lincoln black leg oh my only
check but for me personally the fanboy
is to fanboy ones I got is a cross I
love his stuff man
cross is far from a crucible standpoint
he's just a fun listen am - I've never
met I don't know if he's going um
unknown play is probably number one I
love unknown play a huge fan huge fan of
his content and I totally forgot I
wanted me by gotta throw that in
yes I met bike briefly very quickly like
literally he just got to the thing and I
can tell ya like a a bunch of things he
had to do but I got and he was cool we
start the pig by yeah he's tall like 6-1
6-2 we got there and
well I bumped into Saint say uh what
does it say no to rage very good god I
know you're talking about and the
Guardian radio guys always see them very
quiet
yeah and Dom marking them for a little
bit before so they were very cool like
at the time yeah yeah she's oh it's just
very nice no I mean it's just like it
was a you know contrasting perspective
but it's like coming from that other
side sometimes you got it's like it's
good to hear so I was you ever being
part of that too you know I haven't met
it's kind of weird
good so I saw Roman but I definitely
didn't shake their hand they were just
too insane yes yeah they're swamped that
that thing that's like there they don't
get that chill time they have probably
some room in the back somewhere for them
to be like oh just like sigh but they're
both actually shorter than I thought
they were too funny like I said I being
you haven't been in a while so there's
gonna be fun man just to kind of link up
again and just talk about this game we
love man without fellow nerds in the
building sure in some discussions I
probably owe you a drink in some fashion
I'm not sure if you got one coming to me
but I'm sure I got the kid special for
you on deck we're gonna do this thing
right man gonna set that bar off right
make no mistake but yeah it's just a big
thing to look forward to just got
announced if you're interested tickets
are coming up towards the end of the
month so just keep that in the back your
head look at out planning it out yeah so
it's just one of those pieces it may
sound like a goofy thing to do if you
are relatively close and even like
somebody I know marks and like of
Guardian right oh he's out in like North
Carolina or something and he'll drive
down so like if you can even drive for
reasonable distance for me to be a
16-hour Drive that would just be reheard
'el um but like if you can make it to it
it's always a cool experience and if
you're listening to a destiny podcast
you probably like the game enough that
you might consider it so absolutely just
something to keep in mind and throw in
the back of your guys heads but I mean
it was patch notes and the twelve is
extremely light oh that's most of we got
you got anything else
or out there that was pretty much it we
know it's gonna be a light one coming in
and it's no fun still fun still have fun
with it but yet I think we're gonna be
setting up for um you know obviously the
conclusion of this master Ives mystery
and Thunder Lord and I think me he
talked we should be stuff coming soon
because I mean I got a thinking my um
maybe next week after I would say no
later than the week after because um you
know it is it is November you know this
they you know their rollout thing
usually starts like a little bit of
month right before we do know off record
content creators have come back already
from seeing you know from Bungie and
seeing black army already so um yeah I'm
excited to see where they go I mean I
want to give a small silent prayer to
the devs who are making this after
forsaken OSU the very best the ball has
been said extremely odd you know so just
do the best you can do that's all I
could say whoever's in charge of this
DLC yeah I mean I got a high barter set
because they're gonna have a new
activity potential new space do you
think I'm just gonna utilize what we got
there's so many rumors and leaks I'm
losing track right down the nine it's
just like laying it all down for us but
so it was which one it was he the one
that said EDC expansion area the raid
would be a doozy god she's right I think
for me as long as it's Sal as long as
it's war mind content solid with a
strong enough narrative to keep me
invested in the gone thing and what's
going on and then the key will be the
handling of the red layer the good
they're off to a good start it's not in
the Dreaming city it's not an extension
of the castle we don't go to the
basement I'm good with
we have news like so much stuff in the
Dreaming city I could see that actually
being an okay handling Lake to it I'm
not saying it's we heard enough a rumor
slate but okay
the Leviathan felt so disconnected in
the first place going back there again
had no real connection they already gave
us an incentive to go into the Dreaming
city and have the lure and have the
weekly reset I'll be like what if like I
mean if they did something more with
that I could definitely see how it could
work
Eadie's is they eat haven't how long
have we had the EDC probably for a rate
since I wrapped the machine at least
listen all I'm saying is it just long as
it's not remember eight layers you're
new right it's just not connected to the
prior array that's all I'm saying like I
really don't care honestly even if it as
long as it's not dream scene I don't
care where they go
just give dreaming city a break let it
let has so much to do over there the
Lord's great if something else what
another coat of paint something spruced
up maybe you know now I don't know if
you want to put Seaver back in so early
whatever they decide just I want to go
somewhere new I want to be separate
narrative Lee and I think they're gonna
do it because it I mean obviously
wouldn't on this saying it seems you
know this guy's been on money so far so
it seems like they they already go in
that direction and I get all I want is
content comparable to war Mike site I
really do feel warm on doesn't get
enough credit
I just think war mines narrative was in
well yeah but kind of rushed I would say
which one in a war mind oh yeah I mean
it did feel I mean both of those war
mine does better than Osiris yes Osiris
was just like mercury hurt Mars was
definitely better Mars was a huge step
up so that was good
an endgame of war mine was good I liked
war mines in game yeah
I mean it was an escalation protocol was
a new piece so I was like I mean if they
had done something like the true
infinite forest with Osiris it would
have getting bought them a tiny bit
better reception to that but Osiris was
well and and war mine was alright and
the four seconds like alright I'm
stuffed
so it's been quite quite interesting so
yeah we'll just have to see what goes I
wanted to show you this and kind of get
your thoughts on it now look at screen
look at the date that you have to claim
the triumph for Lunas hell and tell me
when you think it's gonna drop now yeah
[Laughter]
and say Wednesday's of when 2 a.m. yeah
almost two in the morning so I'm so my
hunch for suspicion either the fourth is
gonna be your pre patch for black armory
and it's gonna come out on the 11th or
the 4th is what black army launches good
bro good catch I think you got it I
think it's gonna be like those of us who
stay in it right here fourth or eleventh
I mean it can't be much later than that
anyway I just don't know which one for
thinking they have a pre patch who you
think it is on the 4th I think it's
probably the fourth man because I mean
it makes sense right at the top of
December you know I mean and it gives
you time to get away from the November
craziness people be settling in after
their fallout 76 or whatever big release
November has I forgot right now the call
of duty is not I'm not so used to call
duty be in November
you went out there to get away from Red
Dead but um yeah it makes sense by that
time everybody should be six hundred you
know casuals will be up there you know
Luna's how and then they're probably
introduced a new armed crucible season
whatever you know meta weapon within
glory makes sense I think you got it I
think it's December 4th and that the 5th
is probably just like the placeholders
the last day you can get it done and you
know it's not then like you said maybe
what is it d the following you have the
11th it's like a pre pad
like in between seasons kind of the way
they did forsaken spree badge I mean
just from the standpoint of that they're
giving you up until the fifth yeah that
might even be better to cuz they giving
you up until the fifth to get it done
after that day you cannot get it done
anymore
then you got your pre patch yeah either
way I can see both I literally Canada
now so we'll see but obviously it feels
like it's right around the corner so yes
definitely not far away which is cool
yeah that's the piece that I'm I'm like
this this piece of the annual pass will
set the tone for the next entire year
yeah because if the it's like
everybody's like okay it's the annual
pass worth it what is the season pass
what's the live content gonna be like so
far Forsaken knocked out of the park to
me there's is a perfect no but it did an
amazing job and then you have Festival
loss which came through with a pretty
decent run so I want to interrupt you
real quick stocks although said um he's
got to get away from poking fun but you
have smashed that week also that's right
smash is December no it's much like a
Friday as I'm I believe it's not the
real quick double check was I forget me
we're doing something with smash doing
I'm forgetting a date but um I think
smash might be tough that Friday so it's
the seventh in that day for it is a
Friday yeah I think it's fine if he if
it did the fifth I still think it's fine
they're in a different zone they're in
different lanes so speak yeah I mean why
don't laughing if you play and you just
like a lot of games yeah exactly exactly
so I think they do safety the way so
that's a bad guy yep pretty much wraps
it up guys I didn't want to point those
little couple pieces out good catch
so yeah those one I'm scrolling through
cuz I was like oh I want to get my like
shirt already got that one ordered I
love that shirt by the way yep got that
one going we got you got longer to buy
the ace of spades little figurine but I
still kind of want to get it just for
the just for a little bit of you know
nostalgia for Kade yes and I got the
notification that my anthology books
these routes
yep those are in the works now as well
yeah I pray toward that thing eons ago
so yes sir but I think that we will wrap
it up guys mummy snow thank you for
coming in even though we are coming to
the end of our time this morning but
honestly guys thank you for chat this
morning thank you for coming in and it's
been awesome as always guys we wouldn't
have this without you guys mummy snow
we'll get the archives up so just check
my channel I'll get it up later so don't
worry about that one but for all of you
guys just thank you enjoy your time in
destiny you guys kind words are awesome
you guys are like hey a great podcast
saying just see in those little words it
makes this yeah
means more than you guys know traffic
yeah you want to wrap your piece no
nobody mind yeah at lord Cognito on
twitter at lore cut new please check me
out and when xbox Lord Kanha is well the
iron Lord podcast will be this Sunday 11
a.m. Eastern Standard Time on the island
Lord podcast YouTube channel and
hopefully we should have Lord southbound
he's a main figure in the Microsoft
community so we're trying to get him for
a while he has a ton of knowledge true
gamer he's been on one of my favorite
podcast of all time txr which was the
round table a podcast that's one of my
favorite parts of all time so he's a
veteran in the game knows his gaming
we're gonna be got a lot of litany of
topics so PlayStation guys and use only
guy I mean all the tender guys don't
feel slighted we're gonna have a ton of
Nintendo topics to talk so he talked to
us so check us out 11:00 a.m. Eastern
Illinois podcast YouTube channel
obviously you already know flashpoint is
here every Friday at 9:00 as well as on
ebon says twitch stream really
appreciate the support and yeah we just
been trying to do a lot of game reviews
or slando he's got something coming with
Call of Cthulhu we've got some streamers
going on I want to salute them as well
the ice cream team we're just trying to
get make more content for you guys on
our podcast channel and I'm yeah but
come out on Sunday man if you want to
have a have some fun can we get
ridiculous and in the realm I know you
like every everyone you guys listen to
they may have listened to podcast before
but as soon as they
the one who gets the intro everybody's
just like how do you follow that you set
the bar so high before they even get to
speak and then they're like all right
how's that it pretty well he's like can
you just walk around with can I just
hang you from my shirt pocket you
introduce me that way to all people
everything I like trust me would you
listen to the podcast like when they get
into like the deep dives on those topics
and like some of the nobs those guys
have so good so good so it's definitely
check that out guys awesome stuff for me
probably gonna be working on some solos
I'm working on that hollowed layer solo
100k run I soloed it but working on 100k
and I just hate though I've sold it
before that like I can I figured that
kind of concept out but it's just 100k
with the points and timing is because
the immunity phases is what kills it
that's why it's hard to solo because
it's like oh how long does like it is a
frustration I mean there's a point where
I'm like and get through the first part
I can get up to the tank
if you run what I was saying like
Grenadier with two pulse grenades with a
Titan throw them on there clear out the
ads beforehand I can stand on the
platform get it 90% of the way down get
the ads to spawn then have no ads had
the tank walk out throw both grenades
have him fall down pull out whisper
whisper breathing and kill him before he
can get back up it was like I was going
through there were some people watch my
twittering the other night it wasn't a
ton but there were a few in there and I
was like this is the research that goes
into the videos you guys see like this
is the failing and all that stuff but
it's organic man you do such a good job
man you really do fantastic especially
as a solo player if you don't have a lot
of people who you know rely on or any
type of reliable clan mates and stuff
like that you know I've you I listen
that's no shame like I've used the
buttons god man you know it really helps
because he really gets you in that
mindset and shows the human side as well
as just breaking things down on a level
that is understandable and efficient and
that's your strength so you paint that
picture and get us in there Baras and it
love it love it keep doing it these guys
man they're fantastic
idak actually use one of yours - he want
to shout you out as well
what yes addict he said Charlie Wiseman
he doing this man this is good stuff
Wow oh thanks Adam there you go
alright guys well thank you guys that
has been awesome this morning we will
wrap it up here
I know iron Lords v guess he got his for
me it's he bought us everywhere Twitter
twitch YouTube all of that he be Ont is
search it you'll find me but other than
that guys I do keep getting occasional
requests on my comments about these
getting on something like iTunes yes
I've been seen yeah I was like so we've
got actually look into that and I will
work on trying to do that maybe by years
I don't know what the process is and all
that stuff and it maybe it's easier to
put it on something like pod bean first
and then Spotify but iTunes I know has
it's like process but that will be
something I do want to work on I
basically have to go through and render
out all the audio make those separate
files find a place to stay so but that
is something for the rest of you guys
since you do enjoy that piece of it so
you can watch and just listen to it on
your phone absolutely that will be
working in the future enjoy your
meatball hunting everyone next week is
your third week of the curse remember
shadow throne is back if you haven't
done it go enjoy that thing it's so so
cool
that's one of the pieces that still
blows me away about forsaken is that is
in there there's this extra raid there's
like a raid and then another raid it's
so crazy so alright guys well thank you
enough rambling out is out aside you
guys have been awesome I think we're out
have a good one we'll see you guys soon
peace